I think it is the phrase it bluntly the
rights of farmers it is the arbitrary
distinction that people have more or
fewer rights because they were born in
one side of a border her another side of
a border when she would skip the premise
but all human beings are endowed with
equal rights to have equal value then
there's no moral or ethical
justification treating them differently
simply because they were boring in
different countries we can't grant
everybody writes by invading all the
countries in the world and forcing our
values upon them what we can do is grant
anybody who has the wherewithal her
power to come within our borders the
same set of Rights that we grabbed the
people who were already here I should
add that was the American tradition up
until the 1920s with the exception of
asian-americans all other groups until
the 1920s who came here volitionally
were granted a certain set of basic
rights and the borders were open to them
and that really was the fundamental
difference between the United States and
the countries of Europe you came to
America you had an opportunity to become
a citizen you would an opportunity to
take part in the American dream that's
what the statute of liberty is all about
the people who wave their American flags
and shout about patriotism and at the
same time don't want immigrants come
across our borders or a concerted
illegal immigrants had missed the entire
point of America
it's not at all clear that having more
immigrants come to the country wouldn't
generate more revenue and make more
revenue available to provide the
entitlements that people seek immigrants
tend to be among the most productive
members of our society and historically
people who study this its second
generation for generation Americans the
children of immigrants who are the
powerhouse of the American economy if
you were really concerned about
expenditures on entitlements you would
take people whose families who lived
here for a very long time and we're
being economically productive and you
would deport them and then you would
have more money for entitlement programs
or you would expend Lessing entitlements
in relation to economic progress I think
it's a terrible idea but I think it's
worth noting that many of those same
people are the people who wave their
flags complaining about the criminality
of illegal immigrants